do you think Kanye is dealing with
mental illness right now
yeah yeah no of course I think we all
know that okay do you think Kanye
do you think Kanye is using
the black community right now oh of
course how so
listen
it was hilarious for me to watch him the
flip right right so he's like yo
man George Floyd died from that knee on
his neck was the fentanyl [ __ ] yeah
they canceled his bank they keep they
kept reflashing back to the yo Adidas
won't cancel me yeah yeah we're
canceling him yeah yeah he comes back
and he says yo I'm flipping he did die
from the music I understand now what the
[ __ ] a knee on the neck could do I'm
like yo what it could cost
I'm like what yeah yeah no no no of
course but Kai is always done but what
is Kanye's game explain Kanye's game to
people who don't really understand I
don't even understand this game yeah
because I think he uses yo he uses black
people like we decide chick you know
what I mean yes yo yo the side should
get more attention when you and your
main chick beef and beef yeah you
decides to get more attention when
um I'm like you can take your your main
girl has like an off week or yeah break
up for a while or when you're you know
there's there's certain side chicks that
even when you're single you're still a
side chick so even when he has he's he
got nobody yeah you're still the side
chick so what you side chick you feel a
little bit more special oh I can sleep
tonight oh [ __ ] yeah yeah but at the end
you could realize his ultimate goal and
um I also said this too like I believe
there's a few rappers that I've seen
come through
just entertainment and few musicians in
General that has a innate urge to try to
create a cult and it's not about what
they do right or do wrong they would
have complete control yeah well I don't
even think it's about money necessarily
for yay I think it's about complete
control yeah and he's control the rap
[ __ ] already he's like all right we make
some shirts with some hoes in it it's
fire thought so let me do this it's fire
thought so don't you [ __ ] now let me
go go higher you know what I mean and um
you said who else right yeah
these people don't compare though
because they're not as big I think Nikki
wishes her fan base was a call yeah yeah
but it's not even off that level you
know I mean she's not spreading almost
ideology she's just kind of spreading
stanism you know I mean like yo just
love me unconditionally like using them
yeah yeah yeah yeah just be like y'all
this person just me go get her yeah yeah
I weaponize you the arms will handle it
she says that a lot she doesn't have the
ability to move the world like Kanye
does he really has the ability to move
the world I think X did yo X [ __ ] yo I'm
telling you I had conversations with X I
think he even said on like our last
interview he's like yo if something ever
happened to me it's like there will be a
million people that commit suicide and
like you believe that and the way he put
that down it was kind of like letting
this audience know that
I get like yeah if if I end it all ends
yeah you think that's why he prayed in
every album or that he was just that was
his connection to God that's how I took
it but maybe there's something I knew he
studied Colts though so he studied cult
leaders um I remember one time he called
me was like you gotta go this is my
album this was 17 he says yo cut all the
lights off make sure it's dark sit like
Indian style and listen with like your
hands like folded I'm like cross your
legs
yeah
when you see artists start going beyond
the scope yeah of just hey support me
because I'm making stuff you like yeah
and they're trying to control your
thinking your ideology that's what
they're tempting to do I think I think
do you think you have one no with the
chat no I'm gonna tell you why I think I
don't because at times they hold me
accountable and you can't have a cult if
they're actually like challenging you
like if they're like yo Andrew yo you're
[ __ ] up like that's not cool can you
give an example just to prove your point
to people who don't who aren't believing
you right now like no okay with him no
well [ __ ] they push back on you with
Kanye
um not only that but also I went to
Miami right some [ __ ] happened I wake up
I'm on teams it's just so crazy
and yo you're the prize bro
yo yo holder hold on
hold on wait does the prize want some
ice though